[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
it's week six of johnny depp versus
amber heard
in actuality he's causing his own demise
by bringing these lawsuits forward and
continuing to kind of ignite the fire of
negative publicity around both of them
how experts say this lawsuit has
affected depp's career and an expert
witness gets argumentative on
cross-examination if you want the jury
to believe that expert witnesses are
unethical then i guess that's for them
plus does depp's finger injury match up
with his story did mr depp's finger
injury happen as a result of a vodka
bottle being thrown at him no hear the
expert testimony and later we can't
ignore the beautiful chemistry her and
johnny have together in the courtroom
who is johnny depp's attorney camille
vazquez law on crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer as week 6
begins in the johnny depp amber her
defamation trial herd's team calls a
series of extra witnesses to the stand
law and crime network correspondent
jesse weber is live at the fairfax
county courthouse in virginia with the
key takeaways of monday's testimony
jesse
yeah brian today was very much about
herdside hammering away at johnny depp
from a number of different angles you
know the day started with the testimony
of orthopedic surgeon dr richard moore
and he was of the opinion that the
injury to johnny depp's finger was not
consistent with depp's account namely
that heard through a vodka bottle adam
that shattered while in australia in
2015 but then again on cross-examination
he couldn't really say how depp injured
his finger and he admitted he didn't
consider certain photographic evidence
in his analysis from there psychiatrist
dr david spiegel took the stand and his
conclusion was that depp exhibited
behavior consistent with substance abuse
disorder and that of a perpetrator of
intimate partner violence he talked
about dep's cognitive deficits
narcissism harmful patterns but i will
say on cross-examination by dep's
attorney it was a bit tense and even a
bit comical especially when he defended
his criticism of depp using an earpiece
on movie sets because when he was asked
if actor marlon brando used an earpiece
he responded isn't he dead now i'm not
sure that really was the point there but
from there we moved on to entertainment
consultant catherine arnold who
testified about the downfall of depp's
career an important point because heard
was argued that it wasn't her washington
post article that ruined his career and
reputation but johnny depp
what if any impact did miss herds op-ed
have on whether mr depp
could
claim a loss for pirate six
zero okay
and why do you say that
again well many things
the movie doesn't exist yet so that's
one but
even as important is that disney
in their file for this trial did not
have the op-ed piece as part of all of
the information they had read and looked
about and discussed
the uh conversations of mr depp not
being in whatever new version of pirates
the franchise that goes forward those
were in discussions long before the
op-ed piece even came out
and
there are other factors that disney was
considering the lateness on set
the cost overruns at that cost which can
go from hundreds of thousands of dollars
to millions of dollars when you have
crews sitting around for two to four
hours eight hours or even several weeks
to a month when the finger incident
happened so
on top of that mr depp is an expensive
actor
he can earn between 20 and 25 million
dollars per movie plus back end so it's
very expensive so when you put that all
together
the rise and cost of mr jeff his talent
the challenges that they had to keep it
on budget because of his lateness and
his tardiness and all the other
allegations that would affect a brand
such as disney right
someone talks about a burnt corpse does
not necessarily coincide with the brand
of disney
now we've also learned that amber heard
will no longer be calling johnny depp as
a witness for her side but we also
learned in a change of events that kate
moss will take the stand and testify for
johnny deppside brian
now jesse you just said it there we're
not going to hear johnny depp back on
the stand again but what did you make of
these witnesses that we thought were
leading up to johnny depp taking the
stand they seem to be doing a lot of
pointing the finger at him both in his
career and his mental health status
yeah remember this is the last week of
the presentation of evidence so they're
trying to show that johnny depp is not
telling the truth to the jury that he
had wild erratic behavior and he was an
abuser to amber heard all important
points and also that he destroyed his
own career all trying to defeat his
claim in this last week yeah now jesse
we've already heard witnesses testify
about damages uh to both parties what
does catherine arnold bring to the table
that we didn't hear before
so she did two things she really
articulated what exactly johnny depp
lost as a result of the washington post
article which according to her was
really not what what he's claiming and
number two she also articulated what
amber heard lost i mean she said due to
johnny depp's uh you know statements
through adam waldman that make up the
counter claims amber heard lost 45 to 50
million dollars so again we're trying to
understand how is she getting to that
100 million calendar claim that's what
arnold did for her
yeah but she was comparing and i know
this is a side note she was comparing
amber her to zadaya disney to marvel i'm
not sure if i'm following that but go
for it but kate moss she's supposed to
testify
how's that gonna affect this case
okay other than this being a huge
headline remember amber heard opened the
door by making a reference to kate moss
and the infamous staircase incident that
johnny depp allegedly threw kate moss
down a flight of stairs she's going to
take the stand we understand that she's
a close friend of johnny depp and
probably say that is a complete
falsehood that she probably that he
never did that to her and that is going
to be detrimental to amber heard's case
that johnny depp is an abuser across his
life yeah this is going to be an
interesting summation putting all these
pieces together jesse stick right with
us we'll be back with you in a few
seconds still ahead on law and crime
daily did depp display warning signs of
intimate partner violence
what those signs were and why an expert
witness got tense when questioned by
depp's attorneys
[Music]
welcome back to lawn crime daily after
some contention at the start of his
testimony dr david spiegel told jurors
johnny depp has narcissistic personality
traits and the warning signs for a
perpetrator of intimate partner violence
after was all said and done
that he would apologize
for
letting this monster out
letting this anger out
uh almost routinely
um
and there's very well record evidence of
that
starting as
early early on the marriage and the
other part of this is
again
when you can recognize that when you're
sober
even short-lived sobriety when you could
recognize that
that things are better
things are happening better life is
better
then even that should show you
that hey
there's an issue here there are issues
here that when i don't use
can be resolved
on cross dr spiegel became argumentative
with depp's attorneys about the ethics
of being an expert witness
i asked you whether
under this rubric under this principle
of medical ethics have you acted
unethically
yes or no
no as an expert witness i have not acted
unethically and if you want the jury to
believe that expert witnesses are
unethical then i guess that's for them
to decide
no let's go to the next question
joining us today is law and crime
analyst dina dahl co-host terry austin
and law and crime zone jesse weber dina
i actually thought that dr spiegel
direct had some merit but
that was all seemed to be overshadowed
by his attitude on cross did you get the
same feeling
i did i mean his how he acted on cross
he was so argumentative to the point
that i thought he appeared
unprofessional and it completely dis
discounted what i thought was also
possibly a good direct for amber hurt to
the point that he didn't know how to why
he wasn't willing to answer the
questions about whether or not i was
unethical
it was odd it was very argumentative and
and i think it destroyed his whole
testimony yeah i mean it's only 50
of 20 of his practice i did the math
it's only 10 of his practice maybe
that's the issue terry evasive one
answering direct questions his
descriptions of traits and diagnosis
somehow reminded me of heard explaining
donations and pleds i'm pledges sorry so
who did this witness help
well i think overall the witness did not
help hurt case he was called for her
case of course and i agree so much with
dina on direct he was much better he
wasn't arguing he laid out some facts
but on cross-examination we did see that
there is a distinction between just
listing traits and giving a diagnosis
and he had to admit he didn't do a
diagnosis he did not look at depth he
just listed traits which may or may not
be related to this intimate violence and
so i definitely think he was not that
helpful and i think that on
cross-examination heard's team
definitely lost and i think depp's team
definitely won some points there all
right jesse as two gentlemen who have
ifbs or feeding information to us i know
this came up during the testimony uh dr
spiegel had a lot to say about debt but
now he's not going to take the stand
depp isn't testifying so how is that
going to affect herd's counterclaim
well here's the thing right the counter
claims are asserting that adam waldman
johnny depp's attorney was making all
these public statements calling her
allegations a hoax and that this was
defamation the thing that we didn't get
from adam waldman because there was only
so much he could testify due to the
clear attorney-client privilege is how
much did johnny depp authorize him to
make these statements so calling johnny
depp to the stand we might have gotten
some indication did he tell adam waldman
to do this or not and for the fact that
he has not taken the stand the fact that
he will not be called now the jury will
they will they be able to make that
connection to find the counter claim
maybe by inference maybe they'll think
he authorized adam waldman to make it
but that's the missing piece here and it
might be difficult now for amber heard
to be successful in those counter claims
if they don't get that confirmation from
johnny depp yeah it makes it makes you
think was this about being a court uh a
public opinion or a court of law what
are they trying to get at they can't
reach that basic standard that you laid
out so beautifully for us jesse well
jesse thank you as always for the great
reporting we'll see you next time coming
up on law and crime daily we take a
closer look at day 20 of the johnny depp
amber heard trial
hers team calls an expert orthopedic
surgeon to testify about the severed
finger injury does johnny depp's story
line up with a doctor's opinion
[Music]
welcome back the johnny depp v amber
heard defamation trial enters its final
stretch with the first witness of the
final week being an orthopedic surgeon
who told jurors depth story of how his
finger was severed doesn't line up with
his review of the injury and the x-rays
did mr depp's finger injury happen as a
result of a vodka bottle being thrown at
him objection leading
overrule
i'm sorry
uh no the
medical data is inconclusive uh it's
it's uh not consistent with what we see
in the in the described injury pattern
or in the uh the clinical photographs
and there are there are several elements
there's there's uh you know the
description was of the hand being flat
on a bar and the and the bottle crushing
the finger from the top
but
looking at the images there's really no
no significant injury to the dorsum of
the finger and to create the type of
injury with that with that
type of a crush injury we would
anticipate both injury to the fingernail
and other parts of the finger in the
statements of mr depp that you reviewed
how did he describe what happened to the
alleged bottle when it hit the bar
i believe
he said it exploded
chattered if
a bottle had exploded
near his finger
in the way that he alleges what would
you expect to see in the documents that
you have reviewed
uh well i i think that that the
physicians did a good job of documenting
the presentation the appearance of the
wound
they did not document the presence of
any glass yards
um
and there were no other associated
injuries elsewhere on the hand
all right deanna so just
peeling apart from what he said we can't
say if it was a knife or a bottle so
what's the takeaway from this witness
for the jury
i don't think this witness was all that
helpful because again he's this paid
expert evaluating it but he wasn't the
doctor who was treating him and he you
know kind of admitted to not looking at
all the photographs and also this he was
treated actually in a foreign country
where maybe the note-taking could also
be a little bit different so for him to
really he couldn't definitively say what
caused the injury another thing actually
a viewer in the lunch hour pointed out
was the fact that johnny depp wrote on
the wall afterwards which could have
changed the appearance of the finger by
the time we got medical care i think
that was kind of a really interesting
point but i think the biggest takeaway
for me is he wasn't the one who cared
for it and he didn't really know how the
note taking in australia doctors were
like
yeah with terry with all what dina is
saying with hertz team running low on
time and the judge swearing she'll stick
to that time limit
was this a smart witness to have
well i do think now the judge is
probably going to stick to that time
limit because i think the attorneys are
trying to abide by that but we'll see
what happens but yes it was a waste of
time i think that dr moore wasn't very
definitive and again camille did a great
cross-examination she definitely
made it very clear that this was not a
doctor like dina said who had any sort
of personal knowledge about what
occurred he never examined depp himself
and the best point that camille did was
the fact that the fingers were over that
rail not just laying flat great point
yeah any and he can't tell us one way or
the other so
is the juice worth the squeeze so to
speak in terms of this witness we'll see
when the when the jury makes her
decision when we come back who is
camille vasquez following a strong
cross-examination of amber heard depp's
attorney takes center stage in the case
we take a closer look at her role in the
trial
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
we're taking a closer look now at one of
the key players in the johnny depp v
amber heard trial who has recently taken
the internet by storm law and crime
network sierra gillespie joins us now to
explain who camille vasquez is and what
her relationship is with client johnny
depp
the world was introduced to camille
vasquez during her opening statement for
depp and the truth will come out in this
trial but vasquez really made her mark
with the cross-examination of amber hurd
this was a multi-day assault that took
place over three horrible days
that's not my question entertainment
attorney mitra ahurian says vasquez
asked the right questions in the right
way i think she really stepped up during
cross-examination of amber heard
and
everything we saw about her was good
lawyering
she came in with the right attitude the
right confidence and really had what we
call good control of the witness and
that's key when you're trying to get
your narrative across
is making sure that you're controlling
the testimony of the witness so that
they're not veering off into the version
of the story that they want to tell lawn
crime legal analyst dina dahl agrees
saying vasquez was a standout on cross
camille vasquez did an excellent job on
her cross-examination i mean that's a
really hard cross-examination to do
you're cross-examining somebody who's
alleging domestic violence it's a very
serious allegation and but yet she has
to ask these really tough questions to
be an advocate for her lawyer that's a
very fine line and i thought
she was perfect i can't see anybody
having done it better she was firm she
was really great with the type of
questions just the style of her
questioning
i thought that she was so effective that
i don't know how amber heard quite
frankly come back from the cross that
she did experts say the female direction
in this case is likely a strategic move
it's probably not a coincidence that
they had the two females cross-examine
the two females i think they just don't
like that image of a man cross-examining
a woman on these very sensitive topics
of domestic violence and what about that
noticeable friendship between depp and
vasquez we can't ignore the beautiful
chemistry her and johnny have
together in the courtroom that's really
lovely to watch but is the relationship
something more i don't think they
necessarily have a relationship i have a
lot of clients that i've represented for
a really long time
that i'm
very affectionate towards and i care
about and when they're going through an
emotional
time
part of what you are as one of my
clients calls me consigliati like part
of it is you're a counselor lawn crime
network has reached out to camille
vasquez for a comment but hasn't heard
back yet she and attorney benjamin chu
are expected to present closing
arguments for depp this friday reporting
for long crime network i'm sierra
gillespie
thanks sierra dina you touched on this a
bit in this story but let's dig a little
deeper how do female attorneys play such
a large role in this trial and why is
that so important
you know it may be this outdated
stereotype but they certainly you know
lawyers are certainly aware of how they
are going to be perceived by the jury
and so they don't want to appear as if
they are you know attacking a female
victim who is
you know alleging something that's
really disturbing and so they will often
use a female tourney to do that
questioning in a way to maybe try to
not make it look like there's this man
attacking this woman again whether or
not this is this outdated sexist notion
it does happen for strategic reasons i
do not think it is outdated at all i
would never personally as a 6'4 200 plus
black man come hard and cross-examine
amber heard definitely uh dina or terry
do it terry
i don't think it will happen based on
seniority and the fact that she did the
opening statement but if you had the
choice would you put camille vasquez in
place of doing the closing arguments
well absolutely and i think what they
are going to do is split it like they
did with the opening i do think that
when camille did part of that opening
she wasn't as strong she did get her
legs when she did that cross-examination
and actually i think all three of the
attorneys for depp are excellent i think
ben chu has a role there i think wayne
dennison even though he is not as strong
in my opinion i think all three of them
have had their part in making this so
far successful the star the breakout
star no doubt about it is camille and i
think she will have a stronger voice
when she does this closing and i think
she will help them pull it all together
so if i were them i would have her do
the closing and maybe you know at the
end of the day um be the last voice that
anyone can hear at this trial as far as
depth's team is concerned all right so
dina likes her terry likes her i likes
her but the major question is does the
jury will find out as we continue thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you